good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how to destroy the
habit of complaining let's chat a little
about complainers generally a complaint
is a person who doesn't take
responsibility for their own action a
complainer is someone who would always
talk about why they failed instead of
how to succeed
now there's one simple reason why it's
never ever okay to complain and that is
there's always someone that has it worse
than you do let me give that a little
context so when I think about some of
the things in my life that I'd want to
complain about some of the really hard
things and then I give them any sort of
real world context they aren't that
consequential let me get really specific
when I was 16 years old and I had to
drop out of high school to get a
terrible job to support my new baby
that's pretty rough you know that is a
big enough excuse for me to justify any
actions I take in my life I know but I
couldn't do this because to embrace that
as an excuse to complain but the truth
is that's not so bad
dropping out of high school like really
not having much of a place to live
having no money having a baby being on
welfare like all those things really
suck but in the grand scheme of humanity
it's not that bad
bear with me I turn on my computer I go
to a news site and the first story I
read is about migrants from Myanmar that
are stuck on a boat stranded because the
Thai government won't let them into port
these are people just like you and me
and they're literally starving to death
and this is right now I don't mean to be
so extreme but these are the things that
I remind myself of any time I want to
complain or [ __ ] about something in my
life you realize that there are people
just like you and me who at this very
moment are truly facing things we are
lucky enough to go our entire lives
whatever having to experience okay let
me tell
let me tell one more story to back this
up one more story were like my feelings
around complaining and life in general
were really set straight three years ago
I did this project led like a very small
relief mission to the Philippines after
they had been devastated by Typhoon
Haiyan this is some of the video here
somebody's home
people didn't have water people didn't
have food you know these people had
nothing their livelihood their life
their existence had totally been
stripped away from them and what struck
me the most about the entire experience
all of my time there was not once did
anyone complain but they'd lost
everything
and they didn't complain and they all
focused on one thing they focused on
change not complaining and because that
I do take it personally when people
complain because the truth is most of
the time people will complain have
nothing to complain about who cares if I
went to a meeting that doesn't start
till tomorrow and who cares if some guy
locked up bye-bye brake cable it really
doesn't matter
broken fix it if you don't like it
change it and if you want something take
it don't complain about it just do
something about it
one of the people I look up to most in
the world may be the person I look up to
most in the world tied with my dad I
know damn you might watch us is my
mother and hands down and I mean hands
down the thing that I find most
intriguing about my mom and probably one
of the things that I'm most happy that
she's passed on to me is her inability
almost to complain I find it extremely
attractive I would tell you that I adore
my wife for that reason as a matter of
fact Xander is whining too much and he's
only two and I find it unattractive I'm
very against complaining I'm very put
your head down
I'm very don't you realize you're
healthy like to me the only thing you
should complain about is the unfortunate
unlock of of health you know somebody
dying that you love in a car accident or
you becoming terminally ill after that
it feels controllable and so I I really
dislike complaining I try to I talk a
lot about honey over vinegar it's an
analogy I use a lot here at vaynermedia
I on positivity and so the way I deal
with complaining is I try not to do it
I try to educate and empower people the
lack of it's a it's the lack of its
value I guess I mean I I don't have a
gear there you know when you go on my
gear like there is no like oh let me go
into complain zone to me its assess
figure it out and go directly back on
the offense I'm a very offensive player
complaining is the defense we have a lot
of we have a alibaba group we have a
team or group we have a tarball group
where for a leap a and people say how
you make it why this make it why people
cannot find opportunities you can find
opportunities and I think people same
here today Jeff where is the opportunity
I don't have a job I don't have this I
don't have a debt I remember 20 years
ago I hate a Bill Gates I say he took
all the job you know keys are such a
great a Larry Page Bill Gates and every
success people the
did it good and why I don't have this
chance the same question like you and
later I come down myself
and luckily I win I tell you I'm lucky
to know a lot of famous people Bill
Gates Warren Buffet the Jack Welch Larry
Page Mark Zuckerberg I know all of that
I would have liked to share with you
that those people the difference between
those people and other people they are
always optimistic for the future they
never complain they always try to solve
the problems of the others and I think
where is the opportunity the opportunity
lies always lies in the place where
people complain some people sit there
complain you think if I can solve that
complaint that's the opportunity
I just believe behind every principle is
a promise you know and their principles
out there find a man who's diligent at
his work and he shall stand before it's
their principles man whatever I can't
finally to do do it all I might and
sometimes we get so caught up on I'm not
feeling it today or I don't like that
person or I don't like this circumstance
in this situation you got to get mature
and you got you know you got to be at a
place when you say you're gonna do
something no matter what happens you do
it because again when you start grinding
when you start waking up early when you
when you start you know keeping your
word to yourself to your boss like when
you get go into 120 when you all end by
any means necessary you start seeing
stuff and you start experiencing stuff
and you start having stuff that people
who are not doing that they never get so
for me is like yo you ain't gonna always
feel it like you're not always gonna be
happy you're not always gonna be
energetic you're not always gonna be
pumped up right so you got to get past
that and you just got to make that
commitment to execute and so I just want
to say to those of you out there like
for real man stop whining for real
because when you whine you wasting
energy and you only have so much energy
you only have so many hours you only
have so many weeks so many months so
many years to live and
you wasted whining and complaining you
will never get to your dreams and your
goals but if you just buckle down bear
down and say look I'm gonna get through
this pain I'm gonna get through this
frustration because on the other side of
pain is a reward man you'll have things
that people who wanna complain will
never have and you'll experience life in
a way that they will never experience it
how many of you have ever complained in
your life yeah you know here's what I've
learned about complaining in order to
complain I have to have a reference
point of something better that I want
that I'm not willing to risk creating
now let me explain that again I have to
have a reference point in my mind of
something I want this better than what I
have that I'm not willing to risk
creating so what I do is complain about
it instead see if I was complaining
about my wife it would mean that I would
have to believe that somewhere out there
in the world there's a better woman than
my wife see if every woman on a planet
died except my wife do you think I go to
work the next day and complain about it
no she's the only one
and I'd be going hey I got her this is
really cool right do you ever hear
anyone complain about gravity very
rarely you know gravity makes us all
bend over do you ever see an old person
walking down a street go on gravity they
have a little Walker
I hate gravity don't work for gravity I
wouldn't be all bent over like this
gravity sucks
now have you ever heard an older person
doing it no the reason they don't
complain about gravity is because
there's no alternative to it you know
gravity just is so if someone's
complaining about something it means
they know there's something they can do
about it because we don't complain about
the things we can't change
so as soon as you hear yourself
complaining I want you to stop and say
okay what would I rather have remember a
lot of Attraction always just focus on
what you want not what you don't want
because when you're talking about what
you don't want when you're complaining
and blaming you're focusing on that
which you don't want and you're
accelerating its expression out into the
universe with those negative feelings
and yet we'll spend a majority of our
time complaining about so many things
and usually we complain about them to
people who can't do anything about it
when I had open-heart surgery I died I
used to I used to ask myself I just
wanted to myself I used to ask the good
Lord I was a pray why why did this
happen to me
I have a pretty good person I try to
treat everybody bright I wasn't
prejudiced god I loved everybody I
didn't care what Kody was I'm good so
why why did get a little pygmy why did
it have to be to the 40min one-on-one
fortune time you want to look at to be
string him down and have to suffer like
this for a year and a half after my
surgery 18 months 18 months six months I
had to spend in a wheelchair six more
months I had to sleep sitting down on
the floor with my back up against the
wall because if I lay down I couldn't
breathe
they had to cut my diaphragm during the
surgery whole lot of complication
anywhere I'd sit there I asked him good
lord why why did I have to go through
this
why why why did you do this to me and it
got so bad it was so bad the pain was so
bad my hurt was so bad times done I used
to say Lord if I'm gonna
to live like this for the rest of my
life
then just take me take me now I don't
want to suffer like this anymore
I went to one of many many many doctor
visits that I had at the VA hospital
a young doctor approached me came up to
me said CT I heard you used to be the
champion of the world raised my head up
but had a little little little inkling
of pride still left they told stories
yes obviously T Fletcher
he said what in tho happened to you man
oh you know that hurt me that hurt me
down deep but I'll tell you what if that
doctor was here today I would thank him
because his snide comment is what made
me determine to no longer wallow in my
self-pity to no longer ask God why did
he do this to me my determination
changed from that day on I want to prove
to that little smart wise but I can come
back
that I will steal CT foot now I'm gonna
let his little smart be right I'm not
down I'm not done I'm not through his
over when I say it's over and not before
thank you so much for watching we made
this video because Anna young asked us
to if you have an idea for what we
should do for the next believe like
episode please leave it in the comments
below we'd also love to know which of
the videos that you saw today is going
to make an impact on you what changes
are you gonna make now in your life I'm
really curious to find out leaving the
comments will join the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day if you need to believe and we'll see
you soon